well I live near Shirley Povich so
Shirley which is a male of the
Washington Post was one of them but I
quickly picked up on Damon Runyon and in
Ring Lardner old time and then fell in
love as I grew older with others that
I'd would read like Jim Murray and Redd
Smith but some of the best writing
called Gallico etc was in the sports
pages so it was a happy mixture that's
what I read and that's where they were
it's not up to me to say but I've been
it's been said even in the Village Voice
this week
that I must throw back and carry on the
great tradition of Damon Runyon I don't
know if that's because he wore a hat or
if that's because I wrote the way he did
I mean Runyon was brilliant he's the one
who coined so many phrases gave so many
names like Manassa mauler and others to
athletes and he's probably best
remembered today for something not in
sports the play Guys and Dolls comes
from his short story all of them there
are a lot of short stories in there with
the nicely-nicely Johnson's and Skye
Masterson's the Damon Runyon was
brilliant
sports writing is a almost an extinct
species or soon to be point being
they're writing for blogs and they don't
have a disciplined
once they state a subject they can go on
there's no space restraint and they're
writing quickly so there's no time for
thought cerebral thinking outta an
article they just banging away and in
the old days just to tell you what it
was like when I first came on the scene
I'd been a lawyer and an advertising man
and then after hitting the boss in the
mouth I became a writer and because I
there was nowhere else I could go
nobody'd hire me but we still sit at
bars and tell stories touch shores for
example in New York and we would drink
yes tell stories yes yes and yes and the
young kids at which point I was one
would listen to the old-timers now the
kids don't go to the bars I don't care
they drink have a coke but don't hear
the stories don't go up to your room to
figure out on your laptop how many free
flyer miles you have sit and hear what
it is you're doing so you have a
reference value sports did not start in
1979 with the beginning of ESPN it went
backwards before that I hate to tell the
young writers so no I don't see the
tradition being carried on I'll give you
a story I picked up at two chores I had
to be 40 45 years ago there was a writer
in the 20s for the New York Times who
was still covering when I came on the
scene named John Drebin jure orde revi
who told the story about the time when
the writers would be on the same train
with the ballclub and he was covering
the Yankees and they're going when there
was a Western trip there were eight
teams in the American League from st.
Louis overnight to Chicago they played
the Browns they were on their way to
play the White Sox
I know writers were in the club car
dealing out a hand of bridge and they
were fanning out their cards and the
door slams open and Babe Ruth runs down
the center aisle naked they look up they
fan out their cards more and the door
slams again and here comes a woman
chasing them equally as naked with a
knife in her hand and revi said one of
the writers said well there's another
story we're not going to cover because
that's what it was like in those days
you protected your heroes where are
these young kids kind of hear stories
like that if they don't sit with the old
fogies and listen they're too busy doing
something I have no idea what but it
sure is a Dickens ain't soaking up what
they're covering
Oh several I remember asking Joe
DiMaggio once could you have made that
catch Willie Mays made in the 1954
series off Vic Wertz Joe thought a
second he said I wouldn't have lost my
cat how are they gonna hear that I also
found out why the Runyon's and the
Walter Winchell's and the red Smiths and
the Shirley Povich is and on and on and
on and on
wore hats they warm indoors I mean if
you've ever seen front-page by Charles
MacArthur and Ben Hecht it's been done
four times in movies and plays the
writers are wearing their hats inside
well it goes back to the old old old
days when type was set by Linna type
machines Morgentaler Linotype machines
the hot type they type in the word and
each letter would be typed in and it
would fly in and the filaments would
sort of just spew out all over the place
that they made an a everything that
wasn't an a would go flying on the metal
BC etc well in the old days the jousting
in the floorboards between the type room
which was upstairs and the Edit room
which is right below them because they
were setting up their stories by
pneumatic tube and then it would once
set come down again by tomb rolled up
and do in a ball into a tube it would
come filtering through like a constant
drizzle and they took to wearing their
hats so when I wanted to become a writer
I guess I adopted that which makes me a
throwback no it makes me a hat wearer
but it's fun to wear one because people
identify me as a writer not to put a
press pass in that's if you're insecure
you want somebody to know you're in the
press of course today's kids could just
have a tattooed on their arm but it was
because in the old days all they did was
get this drizzle coming off their hat or
their head
now there had at least they protected
something